FRED SAUER: Can I pre-populate
the data store?
Is there a front end to add,
remove, or update entries in
the data store?
MANDY WAITE: OK, so now I'm
going to punt this one a
little bit, because we discussed
this one yesterday,
and we talked about some things,
some articles that
have been published about
this very thing.
So I'd like to actually talk
to you about that.
Bounce the question back to you
and ask what you feel is
the best way to pre-populate.
FRED SAUER: So, I think the
answer depends a little bit if
you have some data on your
client on your desktop-- maybe
there's some legacy data that
you need to import, some
configuration data that you want
to do programmatically--
the development server, the SDK,
does have a little tool
for uploading data.
That works fine for kind of
small scale, and that's a tool
that's been around
for a long time.
Probably what you want to do
if you're doing anything
larger than trivial operations
is just create a Cloud
Endpoints application or
version of your app.
That doesn't mean you have to
build your entire service
around it, and maybe this is an
administrative gateway or
this is a way that mobile
clients kind of upload data to
your application.
Cloud Endpoints is a great easy
way to create an API and
will automatically generate
client libraries for Android,
for iOS, for HTML5, and from any
of those three clients you
can make your calls to
the server side.
If you're doing Python--
a colleague of ours, Danny
Hermes, has a pretty cool
project called Cloud Endpoints
Proto Datastore and--
or maybe it's Endpoints
Proto Datastore--
but it's an application where
you essentially define your
Python datastore models, and
then you just swap up the
class name that you're
inheriting from, and then all
your classes magically turn
into Cloud Endpoints.
And so you can make calls, like
insert entities into the
datastore, remove them, do
queries, all really easy.
So that's probably the
way that I would go.
And then there's maybe one more
trick up your sleeve.
The SDK has a thing called
a remote API, remote_api.
[INAUDIBLE]
And it's a way for the
development server to
essentially proxy its datastore
memcache requests to
the production environment.
So what you do is you deploy a
special version of your app
with just like a one line config
flag that says enable
the remote API, and then you can
run your code locally as
if you're connected to the
datastore, but everything's
being proxied to the
Cloud for you.
So that's another
neat trick for
migrating data in the cloud.
Or it's a great way
to do debugging.
You connect to your production
or staging environment, and
you can kind of sort of interact
with it while you're
in a Python console.
You have your real data models,
but you're looking at
your real data.
MANDY WAITE: Excellent.